did it ever feel like this is going to  be complicated for the audience or did  you did you have any concerns about it  being um difficult thing for an audience  to grasp or did it feel that it was  something that people could grasp well  it's [ __ ] it you know i mean  so  to give a slightly more sophisticated  answer it's  it's my job as a writer director  particularly to  try and be the audience for the film  i write the script from page one to the  end of the film  i try to be the audience as i'm writing  the script in that way  my hope is that there are enough  signifiers there are enough  familiarities to the rhythm of the piece  i'm putting together that the audience  can feel oriented so even if they're  confused by certain aspects  the feeling of the rhythm in an almost  musical way is is  involving and sort of correct